what what what's the issue with bitcoin
you don't like bitcoin you like bitcoin
i thought that you bought some big oh i
know what's going on no no no no
no issue it's not for me all right
now if you don't think i deserve to talk
about it or you think because it's not
for me because i
looked into it and it wasn't enough by
the way i am constantly looking into it
but for me it's just so so the the
applauding of the yay someone took
bitcoin you know instead of that drives
me a little bit nuts why why does that
bother you i don't know when joe says
what a legend like he's got a legend but
he just took it in bitcoin
why does that bother you
it bothers me because
because he's investing beckham jr
whether you agree with him people
defining him as a role model or not
is a role model and he took all of his
money
in bitcoin and you got to realize
there's a lot of 20 to 30 year olds that
anecdotally have
way too much in this but he didn't hold
on a second but
one key piece of this is because there's
some detail here it's only one of his
revenue streams right my guess is that
it's the smallest revenue stream that he
has compared to marketing deals or other
stuff is that fair yeah he got he listen
he got a signing bonus which is not
included in that but salary is based on
you know weekly that's what you get
that's your check so yes yes but the
thing is that when it's like what a
legend it makes people think that that's
his main revenue stream i'm not saying
i'm not saying odell is in trouble i'm
not saying okay
let me clarify this real quick
you left a legend
darren you left out the part where he
got paid seven figures to do the deal
more than the entire rams contract that
seems like a pretty important part to
leave out but is that what is that does
that necessarily like again i told you
if cash app paid me a million dollars
i'd say no no you said six figures you
said six months
i would if cash make me the offer if
cash app paid me a million offered me a
million dollars i would say no why
because i don't i mean at least tied to
bitcoin tied to bitcoin i don't believe
in it right why wouldn't you just take
the bitcoin and then just sell it for
dollars
because that's disingen again i'm
worried about the youth of america here
i invest in mental health okay but
you're advocating you're advocating for
people instead of taking some of their
salary in bitcoin to take it in dollars
which is guaranteed to lose value
guaranteed to go down over the last two
years bitcoin's up like 350 percent give
or take the us dollar is down like a
gazillion percent well listen i'd rather
take inflation at seven percent than
than than being in bitcoin like the
whole thing against inflation is absurd
the dollar is the most centralized most
recognized you know you go you go nuts
on el salvador you should google el
salvador a little bit more you should
spend more time you should go to elsa
have you gone to el salvador not yet
i'm planning to
you you should because they need help
because 70 percent of the country is
revolting against bitcoin and what's the
deal no no no four million people got
the app four million more than fifty
percent of the elves of the salvadorians
more people have bitcoin
i i'm just i'm just saying that like the
bashing of the dollar the whole dollar
thing is like bitcoin is not the
replacement for the dollar what percent
nobody's saying
it's it's not even on the same level
like bitcoin has no practicality as
currency and that's been proven over
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on what percentage of your
portfolio is in cash
five percent ten percent what do you
think uh in cash uh
yeah i would say about um i would say
less than five percent okay so same
right uh most people that's true now the
reason why you don't hold cash is
because you know because you're
intelligent that the dollar continues to
be devalued right and if you sit there
and you take seven percent inflation on
the chin with you know majority of your
portfolio that'd be bad i don't do it in
cash because because the bank is
offering me nothing yep right there's a
lot of things i can worry about i am
actually not that worried about the
devaluing dollar
i'm not it's not a main concern i am so
happy i live in america and the fed's
gonna raise rates and you know what if i
make my main motivation the inflationary
value of the dollar well you know what i
live in america taxes suck but but the
but the over talk about how the dollar
is decreasing it's the smallest of my
problems and i'm not gonna let that
change my motivation on how i invest and
i shouldn't because it's relatively a
small thing we only talk about bitcoin
specifically we don't tell anyone to go
buy any of these [ __ ] coins there's
thousands of them literally thousands of
them that people could go buy and lose
all of their money we've never told
anyone to go buy any of those
specifically we have only talked about
bitcoin as an investment to go purchase
so in your mind your job for a living is
sports gambling 95 percent of people
lose money on sports gambling it is
essentially a way to funnel money from a
consumer to the state via taxes do you
not find that to be unethical or immoral
at all that you promote that when
one second when bitcoin has a long
history of price appreciation from an
investment there doesn't matter that
doesn't matter at all so you're
guaranteed to lose money in one the
history shows that you're guaranteed to
make a profit in another while
protecting yourself you're not
guaranteed to me history five year
history does
a five-year history in in the terms of
trends or a 10-year history is
ridiculous to talk about a guarantee to
sports gambling and the stock market are
both more fair than bitcoin and i'll
tell you why
sports gambling there is at the very
least at the very least there is some
information you can go on i work at the
action network we specialize in that
information will it definitely help you
win no but
you know that a player is out you know
that there's these trends and by the way
the trends are 25 years that's the
that's what we look at a 25-year horizon
and so
in stocks okay whether you believe the
market is fair or not okay and whether
you think it's a fraud or not it is
loosely based on the earnings of
companies
how the sector is doing and how the
economy is doing bitcoin is based on
zero okay time out i want to compare
stocks and bitcoin stocks i agree with
you it's based on basically macro
environment and then it's based on
things around uh earnings revenue
profitability revenue multiples etc
let's just take nike as an example if i
asked you right now how much revenue did
nike do today nobody knows you don't
know i don't know nobody knows that
answer if i ask you how much revenue
nike did last week nobody knows with
bitcoin
i can tell you every single minute in
real time
how much bitcoin's being created how
many transactions there are what the
network fees or the revenue for the
network is i can tell you how many
people are securing the network
everything is fully transparent there is
it's not a product it's not a pr you're
comparing something like nike that's a
product bitcoin is a product come on no
no bitcoin that's why you go first mover
bitcoin's the first mover who cares it's
not a product no it is here's why
because guess what when you yes when you
go today and you go to starbucks right
you go to starbucks you i take you as
like a frappuccino guy so if you go to
starbucks you order frappuccino no do it
too many calories but
you take you take your corn three i
can't be having frappuccinos they're for
kids you look like you're 19. so you're
still good to go if you take out your
credit card and you put it into the
credit card machine you're using a
product right you're using the visa
network to process that transaction and
use bitcoin hold on but if you were to
pay in bitcoin you would use the bitcoin
network the visa network and the bitcoin
network the payment rails are both
products in the last 24 hours i can
prove to you on the blockchain there was
12.9
billion dollars of on-chain transaction
volume that is not exchanges that's not
trading that's not any of that stuff
12.9
billion dollars there was over 1 million
active addresses the bitcoin network if
you want to do what it doesn't matter
because if it does no it doesn't here's
why it does matter here's why because
visa visa reports that they had let's
say 12 uh 12 trillion in uh annual
trading vol or annual uh transaction
volume last year for what
we don't know they don't tell us for
real for for goods and products maybe
maybe
maybe what else would it be
money laundering we don't know
the banks they say they have transaction
volume what is it for i don't know they
got mexican cartels laundering money
through there like literally they're the
laundromat i want to talk to you about
banks all right let's go do you like
banks or or or uh you know
listen i'm not uh listen uh i'm a
skeptical guy but but my problem with
you is you being two-faced and let me
tell you
oh my god
okay so when we think about pomp and the
banks there's a negative association you
give me that yeah along with 95 percent
of americans also think poorly at the
bank okay so so this so it's like okay
the banks are doing this they're rigging
this they're doing that and then all of
a sudden it's like
goldman
has now put
all their efforts into bitcoin and you
use that as like to embolden people now
you've given the banks credibility
because they're competing they're in
bitcoin you love it no i don't like the
banks i still think the banks are stupid
but they're capitulating they tried to
fight it they tried to ignore it they
said it was stupid they wrote their
reports they banned their employees from
buying it and selling it and trading it
they did all everything they possibly
could they pulled out the banker
playbook and still
you can't ignore the king because they
still capitulate they eventually realize
what the individuals think about this
for a second there are people who sit
inside of all these banks that get made
millions of dollars a year and their job
is to figure out how to improve the
financial system make more money for
their bank and they got front run by a
bunch of morons on the internet the
bitcoin plebs around the world millions
and millions of people figured this [ __ ]
out before they did they didn't get paid
anything this entire system
has been built by millions of volunteers
around the world and those banks realize
if they want to stand toe to toe with a
decentralized network of bitcoin they
will lose and so they have a choice
either you capitulate you bend the knee
and you finally say we're into bitcoin
or you will be left in history books as
being the [ __ ] who ran a bank and got
disrupted by a bunch of people sitting
in their parents basement on the
internet and there's no bank executives
that's going to oversee that disruption